THEY HURT THEMSELVES THE OTHER
DOMINIC DOMINIC BATHERSON ON THE
ICE LEVEL VIEW HERE. LINE
LINE APPLYING AGAINSENATORS TUR.
THAT BOUNCING P IS THAT ATTEMPT.
BLUE JACKETS FINE HERE.
HE SEES AND CLEARED AWAY.
AN ATTEMPT TO SEND IT OUT OF
A
>> WERENSKI IS STILL ON THE HER.
ROSLOVIC ACROSS THE LINE,
CENTERS
TYLER ENNIS ASK WING.
PAGOOD FOR HIM.
>> THAT WAS OUR NATIONWIDE
TELESTRATOR.
UNDERWAY DOES.
IN FRONT, TRIED TO TA
THAT ALLOWS FICKS.
HEEND.
MAX
CYCLING UP.
TRIEDERE TO TURN IT AWAY
AND SEND IT OUT OF PLAY.
>> NOT SURE BEING ON A STICK ON
A 3-ON-2. --
THE RIGHT WING PULLING UP.
PASS.
ROBINSON TRYING TO WALK AROUND
THE
STUTZLE
BACKHANDED.
RIGHT THERE.
>> BOT
NO SHOTS ON NET. FREE.
CLICK FEED IT..ETS SOME HELP
GLOVE.
BLUE END HOLDS.
>>